[Music]
affiliates
was broken what is actually happening
no matter how much riot nerfed him it
was never
enough every single patch has been about
affiliates he has not gotten a single
buff since he's got release
and he's still wasting up there and for
almost a year
he terrorized league of legends
oh yeah with his queue there's the
ultimate gonna land a few extras and
that's what happens with calibration
explain to me what just happened
i don't know i didn't code this champion
but he's busted
a felios for the last year this champion
has
terrorized pro league of legends leaving
behind a trail of plays that left
everyone watching thinking the same
thing
what the hell did i just see
for most of the 2020 season aphelios has
been the premier
80 carry with a kit so complicated that
guys like doublelift had to give his
team a ted talk just to explain how he
works
every time you attack with an ability so
this is his
nine times you get a stack his kit was
insane
it was super unique unlike anything that
had ever been in a league before
he had five different guns he could
switch between with different abilities
attached to each gun and his
alt changed depending on which gun you
had equipped he didn't level up
abilities either
he earned skill points which he could
put into attack speed attack damage or
armor penetration
even his ui was completely different
from every other champion
felios was the most unique original
champion that league of legends had ever
seen
but as fans read his champion primer
they started to get
worried over the last couple of years
wright has made more and more champion
designs that scream broken
and make older champion designs look
like outdated relics
between the super tank horn who gave his
team thousands of gold in stats
or yumi's super heal or zoe picking up
50 flashes a game
players were worried that a felios was
going to be another broken champion that
made them want to uninstall the game
and their worst nightmare came true
it's one free kill waiting for me mr jin
[Laughter]
just six days after he was released riot
had to hotfix affilios
nerfing both his calibrum the sniper
rifle that let him mark enemies and hit
them from anywhere on the map
and his ultimate moonlight vigil the one
that was letting him one-shot entire
teams
still some hope that ophelius wasn't
really broken it was just that people in
solo queue didn't know how to deal with
them
they figured surely that pro players in
leagues like the lpl and the lec would
figure him out and reveal
all of his flaws spoiler they didn't
there's the shock wave coming in but
it's infernum from fbi
on him the whole time and he's still
able to unleash the fire under dignitad
a felios took over pro play
even though he was nerfed athelios could
still do it all
he had caitlyn's style range with
calibrum lifesteal with severum
hard cc with graviton monstrous aoe
damage with infernum and
crazy attack speed with crescendo
currently has caitlyn enabled
caitlyn's a pretty cool champ kog'maw
switches over to
now over to varus with the purple gun
back to caitlyn
back to varus manages to land a
three-man
var assault switches over to jinx
for the aoe damage and then back over to
boris from
the roll back to jinx pretty impressive
i know my champion he's just so many
champions
with all these tools affiliates created
unbelievable moments in pro play
viewers casters and analysts were all
left thinking the same thing
200 years i mean you even see fly going
in there just as punching back
and then we're all reintroduced to mr
200 years oh it's gonna really come down
to a miracle keanu ultimate wallace
doesn't even probably think he can go
for the steal but he might
affiliate how many years 200 years was a
meme that was born on twitter when a
writer ran their mouth a little bit when
talking about balancing wukong
now that comment was made on january 8th
just a few weeks after aphelios was
released and was
one-shotting entire teams so twitch
streamer forest within created a video
about how
200 years of collective professional
game design experience
created a monster and when pro play
resumed
casters and pundits couldn't stop saying
200 years
the meme stuck because kind of
ironically
you needed at least two centuries of
watching a failures in action to
understand
anything this champion was doing and the
hands will be the first one to go down
but mystic grabs that kills vista
on the back line but he's now sort of
one versus four off on the other front
they turn onto the three
the flash forward vista is point blank
range
with the close-range weaponry oh my
god is it difficult to cast a failures
oh yeah
with his cue marked him up there's the
ultimate gonna land a few extras and
that's what happens with calibration
explain to me what just happened
he mocked them and then because they're
marked for some reason you can hit them
across the other side of the map i don't
know i didn't code this champion but
he's busted
sure people were just trying to be funny
but relisa felios had some real clarity
issues
for example it was really difficult to
know what gun he had in his main or his
off hand and when he was switching those
guns
from a viewer and opponent's perspective
it was impossible to understand what was
going on
i want to take this moment um to say
that i am the
i'm the lck color caster and i will
be casting lck tomorrow and um i have no
[ __ ] idea
what that champion does okay i've
probably played against him about a
hundred
times i have no [ __ ] clue
what i'm looking at i don't know what's
coming next
i'm just i mean you just approach them
and you're guessing to their credit
right we're not ignoring the problem but
because affiliates had so many moving
parts
he was pretty tricky to balance at least
in solo queue
this champion doesn't even have a very
good win rate and that's that's like
um something that i think makes it more
complicated to balance right and then
they have to the designers basically
have to decide like okay do we just like
not like what this champion is doing for
the game
and if you don't like what the champion
is doing for the game and you think that
it's unhealthy or unfun or whatever
you can pretty much just kneecap it and
then it's like okay well now no one's
gonna play with elios
so instead of just nuking ophelius in
one go ryan decided to hand him small to
medium nerfs patch after patch
until they found his happy middle ground
and by the end of spring
that strategy was looking to have worked
but then
came summer enter death dance
well we'll see whether this fight is
going to change anything his destiny
will bring fly in there as spirit
with his uh ultimate running keeps
himself alive and that empress divide
was absolutely fantastic it's nothing
in comparison to mystic with his quadra
kill though
is it going to be back-to-back pence's
against sandbox in the first game
it is in patch 10.6 the item
dance receives a little bit of a rework
it lost 30 damage in exchange for 30
armor and magic resist
this was intended to help out top laners
but as any league fan knows
ryan's balance changes rarely go as
intended
index is left alone and will be cut down
eventually let's see how much damage you
can put out
yeah i just wait till household lands
one queue and it's all over yeah
definitely on summer
wait wait a lot of damage it's not done
yet i sigh rotor's death warrant but
he's still alive he next
is looking to get a second he gets a
double kill
the life steal the disc doors what is
happening
is turning around to i'm summer here
comes nukes that is incredible
inax i was convinced you were done i
stopped shoutcasting
after just a few short months of
reprieve people were back to shouting
200 years
and riot had to start swinging the nerf
bat again but this time
some people disagreed some felt that
affilios wasn't broken it was just that
teams actually weren't dealing with him
correctly
if you have any complaints about a
felius it should not be how the champion
is balanced if it's that you don't
understand
felios that's fine because this [ __ ] is
really hard to understand if you're a
pro player that excuse doesn't count
it's your job to play this game you need
to read
many analysts and pundits like ls
believe that aphelios wasn't broken it
was just that teams kept picking melee
compositions into him which
aphelio's hard countered i'm one of the
big dissenters that
affilios is not imbalanced and i think
that we
you see that a lot in games where
affiliate players like struggle to
do anything um and if like you were to
talk to the affiliates player they would
literally say like i just can't play the
game or i can't deal damage but
rather than leave ofelios as he was riot
continued to nerf him
and after his ninth consecutive series
of nerfs
aphelios finally fell out of the top
tier 80 carry rotation
end of the day feliz has obviously
disappeared from pro play for the most
part
he is about varus tier in solo queue win
rate like this champ is actually
just a dog champ while he may have been
broken on his release aphelios is still
one of the coolest champions in the game
riot took a real risk designing
something unlike anything they'd ever
made before
but balancing issues have distorted
players views of him forever
he will forever be associated with being
broken
and he's not alone riot keeps releasing
new champions with experimental kits
they can't design the same kind of
characters forever after all
but they run the risk of creating
another affiliate
and as these kits become more
complicated and unique
they have to ask is experimentation
worth breaking their game
in half thanks for watching if you want
more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages